DANIEL FRIEDMAN: Hello and welcome
everyone. It's July 13, 2023. We're here
in physics as information processing
with the third lecture by Chris Fields.
So please check out the course website,
Coda Document, where you can submit
questions, check out the recordings and
descriptions of all sessions, and
register if you want to participate in
one of the discussion sections. So thank
you again, Chris, to you.
CHRIS FIELDS: Thank you and welcome to Physics as
Information Processing, session Three,
which is about quantum reference frames.
So in this course, we've talked about
quantum information theory, which we
characterized as a general theory
that describes the exchange of
information, exchange of finite
information between two finite
agents that are separated by some
boundary. And we emphasize that this is
a topological theory, not a geometric
theory, so it makes no assumptions about
an embedding spacetime.
And last time we showed how to
characterize this boundary of script B
as an array of N,
some finite N quantum bits or qubits,
and how to characterize the interaction
of the agents A and B with the boundary
as an alternating cycle of preparing
and measuring the qubits in this array.
And we showed that their interaction
could be represented as a sum of
operators, each of which act on just one
of the qubits. And we also talked about
the need for each of the agents A and B
to choose a reference frame for their
interaction with the qubits that defined
which way was up. So what
the orientations of the qubits meant and
emphasized that the two observers A
and B could choose different reference
frames, so different ways of measuring
and preparing their qubits that use
different meanings for the idea of up
for each qubit. And we ended
the last session with a pointer forward
toward the quantum formulation of the
free energy principle, which can be
stated as the claim that interacting
systems behave in a way that aligns
their reference frames. And pointed
out at that time that what this means is
that the two agents A and B approach
entanglement asymptotically, and that
therefore the FEP is a classical limit
of the principle of unitarity, which is
the core principle of quantum theory.
So we'll see in this session why this is
true. So what we'll
talk about today is what reference
frames are in general, how they
make observations and actions
meaningful, so how they give physics a
semantics, and then we'll talk about the
free energy principle.
So what is a reference frame? The idea
that physics involves reference frames
goes back at least to Galileo, but was
probably familiar well before that,
just not formalized in the way that
Galileo formalized it.
So the key idea can be thought of in
terms of motion. And you're all
familiar, for example, with riding a
bicycle or driving a car and seeing
the world as if it's passing by you at
some velocity, with some velocity. And
of course, with respect to the world
you're passing by it with some velocity.
And this idea that velocity is
not absolute but that's relative to
some observer who measures it in some
reference frame is the foundation for
theories of relativity. So Galileo
developed his theory of relativity which
basically was just a way of converting
from classical velocities measured by
one observer to classical velocities
measured by another observer that was
moving with respect to the first one.
And this provided the foundation for
Einstein's theories of relativity which
modified Galileo's by adding the concept
that the observers have to change
exchange information and can only
exchange it at the speed of light which
is finite.
So this idea in physics has a long
history. Of course, the core idea is
that measurements are always with
respect to something or other. And the
something or other is a reference frame
and different agents can choose
different reference frames. And this
idea is very old. Here we have a picture
of anubis choosing a feather as the
reference frame with which to measure
the heart of the pharaoh. So this goes
back to well before the common era.
This is about 2000 BCE.
So this is a very old idea that's been
elaborated over the centuries as science
has developed and in the
fairly big change in how this idea was
thought about occurred in classical
physics reference frames were always
thought of as mathematical abstractions
and an observer and a reference frame
were more or less identified by Galileo.
And that identification is carried
forward into Einstein who thinks about
observers, for example, sitting on
photons and observers in spaceships and
observers riding on railroad trains and
this sort of thing. And always that just
means think of a reference frame that's
doing something or other.
So a
reference frame in classical physics is
essentially just a coordinate system and
these abstract coordinate systems can be
employed in thought experiments and
so they are a way to illustrate
classical intuitions about motion.
And in the 90s, as quantum information
theory developed it was realized that
a reference frame actually consists of a
physical object. I mean, even in the
picture from the Egyptian tomb the
reference frame is a physical feather.
And that means that the reference frame
itself is described by quantum theory.
It's some quantum system.
And if you think about reference frames
that are familiar for example, meter
sticks for measuring distance or clocks
for measuring time or gyroscopes or
batteries or even the Earth's
gravitational fields which typically
defines up for us those are all physical
objects that can be described by quantum
theory. Well, this was an important
insight because it led to
the realization that reference frames
as quantum systems are unique.
And uniqueness in quantum theory is very
strong. There's the no Cloning
theorem which states that you can't
reproduce exactly reproduce any unknown
quantum state. And that
applies to reference frames because they
encode what Bartlett et al. In that
paper called non fungible information
which just means information that can't
be completely represented in any finite
bit string. So unless you know the
state of a reference frame, you can't
clone it. Since these reference
frames encode more
than any bit string's worth of
information in their quantum phases,
they're unique and their states are
unknown. And the consequence of this is
that if Alice wants Bob to use
her reference frame to make a
measurement, she can't just send him a
description. She has to actually send
the reference frame.
And this has an important consequence
for physics because it makes all
replicate measurements approximate
because observers obviously aren't using
exactly the same physical objects as
their reference frames. But there's a
deeper implication of this,
which is that Alice's ultimate
rock bottom reference frame is actually
implemented by her body, by her brain.
And using any external reference frame
requires having this internal reference
frame that makes the external reference
frame meaningful and usable. So,
for example, this thing is a piece of a
meter stick, a third of a meter stick.
But for me to use it to make
measurements, I have to actually have
some concept of distance. And that
concept of distance is implemented by my
nervous system. And that implementation
is my reference frame for length.
And it's what gives meaning to any
external measurement of length. It's
what makes my measurements of length
actionable by me using my effectors
or action capabilities, whatever they
are. So my internal reference frames
are what make information I get from the
world actionable. And in Bates
and sense of differences that make a
difference, actionability is the core of
semantics. Something is meaningful if I
can do something about it. So this idea
that we all contain embodied
reference frames gives physics a
semantics by giving observers a
semantics. And this is new.
This is an idea that never really
appeared in physics before that
measurements automatically had to have
some kind of semantics. But reference
frames give semantics to measurements.
So here's an example of an embodied
reference frame. This is the reference
frame that bacteria use for chemotaxis
I. E. To move toward molecules in the
environment that they like, like sugars
and to move away from molecules that
they don't like, like acids. And it's
been worked out in great detail over
decades of experimental work. And this
is a rough schematic. The reference
frame has three parts.
There's the measurement part, which is
conveniently located in the front of the
bacterium. And it consists of a bunch of
receptors that probe the environment.
And they can bind molecules, which are
called ligands, out in the environment.
And when they bind them, they send a
signal into the back of the bacterium.
And it turns out that there's a little
miniature reference frame attached
directly to these ligands which is this
r and B system which control the
ligands, not the ligands, the receptor
sensitivity. Then the back of
the reference frame is the action
component and it consists of a set of
molecules that control a motor,
a molecular motor, that drives the
flagella on the bacteria. And the
flagellum allows it to swim forwards or
turn in some other direction. And
depending on how it spins, the creature
either goes in the direction of
something it likes or it stops and turns
around. And the stuff in the middle is
a little molecular feedback loop that
represents the amount of ligand in the
environment that the bacterium expects
to see. So this is the middle of the
reference frame and it defines the
default value for what the bacterium is
observing in its environment. And if
you're thinking in terms of the free
energy principle or Bayesian inference,
then you'll immediately see the
concentration of this molecule is
encoding a prior probability, the
bacterium's prior probability for what
its environment is like. And the
zero point, the default value of that
encoding, is the ligand concentration
in which the bacterium does nothing.
So a QRF in general
can be characterized as an expected
value, which is here the concentration
of this molecule p y phosphorylated
plus a bunch of computation, which is
all the rest of the things in this
diagram. So this is a very simple
QRF that's embodied by a bacteria.
Here's a more complicated QRF that's
embodied by eukaryotic cells,
or more complicated cells like our
cells. And this is the reference frame
that makes decisions about whether cells
are going to divide. So on the top
you see the cell's membrane, and there
are all sorts of receptors sticking out
of it that detect hormones and
neurotransmitters and growth factors and
this, that, and the other thing, many of
which are produced by other cells.
And those receptors communicate
via a lot of chemistry with
the nucleus, which is contained in
another membrane and so
serves as, in a sense, the outside upon
which the reference frame is acting.
And what this reference frame does is
control the transcription of large
numbers of molecules from DNA. So it
basically controls what proteins the
cell is making. And those proteins end
up doing something like restructuring
the cytoplasm and actually driving cell
division. And the stuff in the middle of
this reference frame, which I've labeled
the integrative center, are three
molecules called RAF, mech and ERC.
And they're connected by positive by bi
directional feedback loops. And they
basically negotiate the default value
of the environment at which the
cell does nothing. So they're
the middle of the reference frame that
represents the cell's expectation values
about what's going on in its
environment. So you can imagine now what
reference frames encoded by our nervous
system look like. They're extremely
complicated and exist at multiple
scales, from the scale of molecules in
cells to the scale of large scale
connections between parts of our
brains. So how
do we represent all this stuff?
There are many ways to do this, but this
is a particularly simple way.
It assumes that whatever's in the
middle, which is here called C prime is
the most general thing that
the inputs can give information to and
the most general thing that can give
information to the outputs. And most
general here has a category theoretic
definition so it
can be stated in a way that's equivalent
across many different specific
mathematical forms. But if you're
familiar with neural networks, this will
look to you a lot like the skeleton of a
variational auto encoder. And that's
basically what it is. And I don't want
to deal with this formalism except to
say that it exists and is very
convenient, except to say that we can
attach this kind of formal
diagram as a representation of a QRF
to our representation of the boundary
between two interacting agents. And we
can use these formal structures to
drive the measurement operators that
actually implement physical changes on
this boundary. And I'll
represent this whole business with just
a triangle labeled Q for some QRF that's
attached to the boundary. And we can use
this simple notation then to investigate
what sorts of structures one gets when
one starts to think about systems as
implementing specific QRFs.
And here's the structure of the minimal
system that we can really think of as an
interesting observer. And this is
a system that has some QRF that
I've called E that looks at its
environment, the part of its environment
that it can actually observe and act on,
and it defines a sector of
the boundary which mathematically is
just the image of this Qrfe that
the system can manipulate. So this is
the part of the environment or the part
of the boundary that the system actually
sees and can do something about.
And for this observer to be interesting,
it needs to be able to detect the
difference between what it sees now and
what it saw just then so that
it can decide whether to take some
action or other. So it needs a memory
and that requires another QRF that
has some allocated piece of the boundary
recall. The boundary is where classical
information gets written in this purely
quantum theoretic formalism.
So it needs a memory sector that that
QRF can act on. And then in
order to do this computation and
specifically in order to write
information to the boundary, in order
to actually flip bits on the boundary,
it needs free energy. So the rest of its
boundary gets devoted to extracting
free energy from the environment and
exhausting free energy, waste heat, in
other words, into the environment. And
so it has this nice little thermodynamic
cycle that drives everything else. And
finally, in order to tell now from
just a second ago the information in
memory, it needs a clock that
marks the information in memory as not
current, so as past information.
And if it can store multiple memory
records, it needs to be able to count
and say this piece of remembered
information is actually more recent than
that piece over there. So it has to
implement a little internal clock, and
that clock is its internal time QRF.
And we've seen that QRFs act on
boundaries. This clock acts on a
boundary, but it doesn't act on B. It
acts on an internal boundary that's
essentially the boundary between it the
clock and the points at the ends of
these QRFs that actually encode
information that's either read from the
environment or written to the
environment. So already this
minimal observer has a little bit of
hierarchical structure,
which is that its clock has to, in some
sense, be higher up in the hierarchy
than the parts, the QRFs that interact
directly with the environment. So if you
have a structure like this, you face a
metabolic trade off for a fixed amount
of energy that you can extract from the
environment. You can allocate it either
into learning more about the environment
or remembering more about what you
learned before.
So any system has to make this
decision about how they're going to use
energy. Are they going to devote it to
learning more or remembering more. And
your laptop makes that decision. Memory
is cheap for your laptop. Your brain
makes that decision. Memory is much more
expensive for your brain. And all cells
have to make that decision. And the
universal solution to this trade
off is course grading memory. I e.
Remembering things in less detail than
you saw them in the beginning. Ander Aguirre,
you have a comment?
ANDER AGUIRRE: Yes, I wanted to ask a question now before it
gets too late. So two or three slides
ago, when we were looking at the
diagram of the coconut diagrams, I was
wondering if the classifiers
identified with measurement and
preparation. Those correspond to sensory
and action degrees of freedom in the
earlier picture with the bacteria and
the classifier in the middle in
that picture, would it correspond to the
default chemical concentration? That
yes, exactly. Okay,
perfect. Yeah.
That crossing point in the middle is
specifically where the default is
encoded. Thank you for pointing
that out.
Okay, so let's follow the consequences
of this metabolic issue.
If you have a system that's a little bit
smarter than our minimal system that can
actually detect and measure the states
of objects, it has to do even more
work because it has to encode even more
QRFs. So think of measuring the state
of some object like a volt meter in a
laboratory. If I tell you to go into the
lab and tell me what the voltmeter is
reading, then the first thing you have
to do is find the voltmeter. And your
process of finding the voltmeter is
independent of your process of reading
what it's actually saying on its dial.
So in order to measure the state of an
object, you have to have two QRFs one
that lets you find the object, and then
the other that lets you measure the
state of interest of the object. And we
call these the R sector for reference
that lets you find the object and the P
sector for pointer because old
instruments used to have pointers on
dials that read analog numbers.
But what thinking about object
identification tells you is that every
object that you can identify leads
to having to sector both the informative
part of your boundary and the memory
part of your boundary into two new
sectors one to store information about
object identification and one to store
information about the states of those
objects. So this requires much more
metabolism. And again,
the solution is coarse grain.
Typically, what we coarse grain is our
memory of the object that we've
identified. So what
does this do to systems?
Because making measurements costs energy
and recording memories costs
energy. We have to make decisions
about what QRS to use at what
time. Given our finite energy budgets,
we can't look at the world with all of
our measurement capabilities at the same
time because it's too expensive. And now
we see the effect of a theorem in
quantum information theory which is that
if two QRFs can't be deployed
simultaneously for whatever reason that
corresponds to them not commuting as
operators and if they don't commute as
operators, they have to be implemented
by compartments that are separable. So
compartments that only communicate
classically. The consequence
of this theorem is that as soon
as one has too many
sensory and motor capabilities to run
all at the same time, given your energy
budget you end up being
compartmentalized into compartments that
only communicate classically. So you end
up looking like this diagram where there
are a bunch of components that do
sensory motor, loops or memory,
one or the other and they can only
communicate classically. And they're
controlled by some sort of attention
system that selects which
ones to activate depending on the amount
of free energy that's available. And
clearly, this clock function becomes
part of this control system.
So the physics alone of
any system that's acting as
that executes a fairly complicated
interaction with its environment gives
us this hierarchical compartmentalized
structure without having to add
any biological or cognitive science
type assumptions at all.
So we can go in three directions from
this. We can go deeper into the
biology which we're going to do in
October. We can go deeper into the
physics which we're going to do in
August and September and we can
go deeper into this issue of alignment
which is what we're going to do today.
So there are four possibilities. If you
think about two agents that have QRFs
that are interacting across this
boundary and the first one is trivial.
If the B agent, the agent on the right
side, doesn't actually employ
any QRFs if it just interacts with the
boundary thermally, then there is no
alignment. You're in a trivial situation
where A can measure something about B,
but not in return.
If the B agent deploys a QRF
that's much broader in scope than the A
agent what we show here in panel B,
then the A agent can learn something
about the B agent but misses most of
what the B agent is doing.
In panel C, we have agents with QRFs
of the same size on the boundary, but
they're not lined up correctly. So each
one misses part of what the other is
doing. And finally, indeed, we have the
optimal situation where they have QRFs
of the same size and they're actually
lined up. So each sees what the other is
doing, at least on this sector of the
boundary. And since the agents have to
allocate some of the boundary to free
energy supply and can't look at that
part, then they can't tell what's
happening across their entire
boundaries. They can only tell what's
happening in this sector where they can
actually deploy a QRF.
But let's now look at this interesting
situation, situation D, where the
QRFs are allied between A and B.
As I said, that's the optimal channel
for A and B. And if
we think about this, we can write the
variational free energy or the
uncertainty or the prediction error for
A for the Qrfx
as the action that
it sees I E B's
action, the difference between that
and what it expects B to do. So what
it can predict about B's action.
And this is just the notion of free
energy from the free energy principle,
except translated into this
situation where we have two QRFs and
A can measure what B has done, but it
can also use its QRF to predict,
because it's predicting the very state
that it's going to observe next of the
same sector that B is using.
Now, if we look at this diagram,
we can see easily that the way to
minimize the variational free energy and
therefore maximize predictive capability
is for these two QRFs to actually be the
same. So if A is
doing the same thing to the
boundary that B is a can predict B's
next action perfectly because
B is going to do whatever A is doing.
So what the
free energy principle tells us in this
case is that A and B,
as they minimize their variational free
energies, will approach having identical
QRFs. Well, again,
we have a theorem that tells us that if
these QRFs are shared, a and B
are not separable but entangled.
And this is also fairly easy to see
because it depends on this notion of non
fungibility.
If XA and XB both encode non fungible
information, which is quantum systems,
they do. Their states aren't clonable,
so they can't be copies of each other
because one can't clone an unknown
system. So they can only be identical if
they're actually identical systems.
This is exactly the same point made
earlier about Alice having to actually
send her QRF to Bob if she wants Bob to
use her QRF.
So minimizing VFE
for quantum systems is becoming
entangled. So the classical free
energy principle, which tells us to
minimize VFE actually drives quantum
systems toward entanglement. And that's
why it's a special case of the principle
of unitarity which just says that any
isolated joint system is going to
asymptotically approach entanglement.
So this raises an obvious question,
which is why all of us aren't entangled
with our environments all the time and
entangled with each other?
And the answer is that entanglement is
really hard for complex systems. And
this illustrates the sense in which the
FEP is moving systems in two different
directions at once. The FEP
is driving systems to maintain their
separability but it's also driving
systems toward entanglement. And as
the system becomes more and more complex
the difference between those two
outcomes becomes larger and larger.
So recall from last time that the
condition for separability is that the
two systems have dimensions that are
much larger than the dimension of their
boundary. And this is the condition that
allows them to have internal states, to
have them have states that aren't
located on their boundaries. And
clearly, to formulate the free energy
principle you have to have internal
states. So if you do
a complex QRF that's in a lot of
computation then you need a lot of
internal degrees of freedom to implement
that computation. So you need a lot of
internal state. So you have to have
large dimensions. So complexity
favors separability. As a system becomes
more complex, it has to have more
internal states. So it has to be, in a
sense, more separable from whatever it's
interacting with. Now, think about this
classically. If you have a complex
system that's doing a lot of computation
then it requires a lot of free energy
and it has to dissipate a lot of entropy
in the form of heat, typically but
something, some form of energy transfer
that its environment is going to see as
noise, as not informative.
So a complex system is working very
hard to predict its environment's next
state. But by working very hard it's
dumping a lot of entropy into its
environment. And putting in that extra
entropy makes the environment's behavior
even harder to predict. So the more you
work at predicting what the environment
is going to do the more you yourself
make the environment's behavior less
predictable. And this is the paradox
of the FEP, which is not really a
paradox. It's just what the physics
does. So we can think of
the FEP by driving systems to
increase their distinctness from their
environments or to self evidence, as
Karl Friston calls it,
as driving this increased
complexity that both makes predictions
better and makes predictions harder
by transferring entropy into the
environment. So what this tells us is
that the FEP by itself will
drive the development of systems with
larger and larger complexity. And this
clearly has enormous implications for
evolutionary theory which we'll talk
about in October.
But I want to emphasize here that this
is just the physics. It's just what the
FEP does when it's forced to maintain
a boundary.
And before stopping here,
I want to consider one aspect
of this in particular, which is
language. For example, human language,
but any kind of language connecting any
systems that are communicating with QRFs
that are fairly close. And language is a
complex QRF that we basically
share. Otherwise, things like this
interaction would be impossible, but we
also remain distinct systems. So the
question arises, how do we manage to do
this? How do we manage to largely share
a QRF while escaping,
becoming entangled?
And this is a question that's largely
been ignored in physics because
physicists have tended to ignore
language and just assume that observers
can communicate classically. So, for
example, in talking about a Belly PR
experiment, which is a canonical
experiment for measuring entanglement,
the observers have to be able to share
their results, or they can't observe
entanglement, right? The observed
result is a bunch of observational
statistics that violate Bell's
inequality, and those statistics can
only be computed given the results that
both of the observers obtain. So the
observers have to share language to
encode these results.
So how come the observers aren't
entangled? How come they are still
separable? What we end up appealing
to is some sort of common cause in the
past to explain why they share a
language. They both learned it from
their culture, so their culture is some
sort of common cause. But all such
assumptions are fine tuning assumptions.
So they all have basically the
status of the
value of something like the fine
structure constant, without which we
wouldn't have atoms and so we wouldn't
have us. This value has to
be within very small limits
of the value we actually observe. And
that's a case of fine tuning. The
universe seems fine tuned in a way that
allows us to exist. And if it
wasn't fine tuned in that way, we
wouldn't exist, and so we wouldn't
observe anything. But fine tuning
assumptions are a problem. They're a
pointer to something we don't
understand. And so I just want to leave
you with the point that we have to be
very careful when talking about
interacting observers. So in
talking about two components of
some system that jointly interact with
some environment but also communicate
classically, and if you think back a few
slides, that's exactly the structure
that we've shown that the physics forces
any complicated system to have.
So next time, what we're going to focus
on is this very question of how we
describe observers that are both
interacting with the quantum system and
communicating classically in some
language. So that session will
be in August. At the end of this month,
there's a discussion of this session
with Aguirre, and I encourage you all
to use the interactive
Q and A to ask questions. You've been
asking very good questions that I hope
I've been managing to answer.
So thank you very much. And Daniel.
Over to you. Cool. Well. We have
a few minutes for some questions maybe
and or if you want to bring up any
questions first,
then go for it.
I was curious if you could say any words
on the slide where you had all the
possible alignments of QRFs and what you
meant more by interacting thermally. So
when you have a trivial agent on one
side, what exactly does it mean to say
that you're interacting thermally?
If you think about a system that is only
interacting thermally with its
environment,
you end up thinking classically about,
for example, an ideal gas that's in some
sort of container and some of the
molecules are very near the surface and
their motions depend on the motions of
all the other molecules that are inside.
So there's a set of internal
states that interact randomly
with the external states that are near
the boundary and so those external
states interact randomly with the
boundary. But notice in thinking in
this way, you've imposed a spacetime
embedding, so you've actually used space
as a way of separating the internal
states from the boundary states.
And a system that if
you drop this assumption of a spatial
boundary, then a system that's only
interacting thermally with its
environment is going to look like a
system that doesn't have any real
internal states. It's going to look like
a system that just has boundary states.
And so a pure thermal interaction is
going to start to look like
entanglement. So we're
actually only really interested in
systems that aren't interacting only
purely thermally with their
environments. We're interested in
systems that have enough internal
structure that they're using that
thermal energy to do something
internally. So to give
their internal dynamics some particular
shape, so that their internal dynamics
is actually circling
around some well defined attractor that
requires some energy to maintain itself.
Yeah, I'm continuing with that question.
I saw in the paper free energy principle
for Quantum Systems that if you're in
that situation when both keras are
nontrivial, but perhaps B's is larger
than a's ace perceives non
local hidden variables. So I wonder if
there is a way to relate those by taking
a limit of making a small and recover
the thermal interaction. Presumably if
you let A become small, you should
recover that thermal interaction, so to
speak. Right? Yeah, that's a very
interesting comment actually. So if
you're a system and all of your
environments variables are effectively
hidden to you, then you can't do
any information processing because you
don't have any access to any of your
system, your environments variables. So
yeah, your interaction can only be
thermal. I think that's correct.
Thank you.
Since we're in this, in this topic and
we don't have to context switch in that
way. On the other hand, you have noise,
right? In one of those other situations,
I can't recall which one. I guess in
the reversed one, right. When a's QRF is
larger than that of B, so it encompasses
more of the boundary degrees of freedom,
those that are not overlapping A
perceives as noises. That's correct.
Right? Yeah. A will be looking at
B's thermal sector, b's free energy
sector. Right. So A
may be interpreting, in a sense, what
it's doing as informative,
and A may even be seeing what B is doing
as informative.
So noise for B may be signal for A,
depending on how a's QRF is
structured, but A
is seeing more information than B
is trying to send it.
So it's it's essentially the the reverse
of the hidden variable case. There are
variables in the other system
that aren't telling you anything about
what the other system is actually doing.
That's very interesting in terms of
reading too much or too little between
the lines, connecting too many dots or
connecting not enough dots. But these
challenges where noise for one quantum
cognitive agent might be signal for
another and vice versa, those are the
challenges that we want to address.
Because to have a physics that doesn't
recognize those situations is kind
of taking the view from nowhere or not
really addressing the complexity of a
cognitive engagement.
Yeah, it's describing interactions
between, effectively, systems that don't
share the same language.
I have a question about the free energy
principle here. Only in the
last several years has the quantum
free energy principle relationship come
into light. So maybe could you just
share a little bit about what
incremental or quantum advances
enabled that to happen? Or what degrees
of freedom were preexisting or
added to enable work arising
from perception and action in neural
systems to also so naturally enter
this context with the quantum
information?
Well, I think, at least from
historical point of view,
that connection was made based on the
analogy between a Markov blanket and a
Holographic screen. So these are
structures developed in different parts
of physics that essentially serve the
same function of limiting the
information that one system can have
about another system. So it's
that functional analogy between
a Markov blanket defined classically and
a Holographic screen defined in quantum
theory that made
it seem obvious that we could translate
the free energy principle into a quantum
theoretic principle.
Yes. In live stream 40, we talked a lot
about this, but I think that remains one
of the most remarkable advances
inside or outside the free energy
principle literature based
upon this functional acknowledgment of
boundaries and the conditions that they
entail, which, again, are the challenges
that we want to address lest we ignore
boundaries. Right? Yeah, precisely. I
mean, the free energy principle is all
about what happens when you have a
boundary.
The waste heat.
Is this the actual thermal
exhaust from our CPU? Or how
can we think about the heat being
released topologically rather
than geometrically, like the location
where it's released? What does it mean
to consider physical processes
topologically that we might otherwise
just use a geometric way of thinking
about? Well,
you basically put your finger on it and
that you're not worried about the
spatial difference between the
geometric spatial difference between
where one kind of information flows
through the boundary and where another
kind of information flows through the
boundary. And you can think
about this in Markov blanket terms.
And the Markov blanket is just a
network. And some
of the causal arrows flowing through
that blanket network are effectively
transmitting noise.
And you can think in the same way with
respect to a holographic screen if
you're doing a certain amount of
information processing. And this this
brings up the whole issue of how
how efficient is a system in
its information processing? How close is
it to the land hour limit? Basically?
Can it extract more
energy from some bits than
it has to use to modify the states
of other bits? That's what this,
if you will, metabolic question is all
about. In the case of an organism,
is it can I get more energy from some
of the chemistry that I have access to
than I need to use to modify the
chemistry that I need to modify?
And if not, then life stops.
Everything grinds to a halt.
Now, can the heat exhaust
informationally be useful for another
agent somehow? I mean, can't we recover
heat in a steam engine and use it to do
useful work? Not to the point of a
perpetual motion machine, but how can we
recover exhaust? And then what does the
perpetual motion machine look like?
Well, the environment is the system
sitting over on the other side of the
boundary that is absorbing
whatever waste heat is generated by the
system. Let's call it Alice
that we're interested in. So that
environment may be alice
can't tell this, but it may be divided
up into lots of different compartments,
some of which are basically sucking in
Alice's waste heat and doing something
with it. So this
is really a question about how is the
environment structured and
what operations does the environment
execute with the input that
it gets? How does it interpret that
input?
And what would.
This gets back to this question about
how do we talk about multiple agents
that are communicating with each other
instead of talking about an
environment that we don't characterize
at all? How do
we talk about an environment that
includes some specified or preferred
systems that are treated as
or known to be other agents?
Let me get back to your question about
perpetual motion machine. Notice that in
classical thermodynamics there's always
the assumption that there's a big
environment out there the rest of
the universe or whatever, the whole
environment that's not on Earth. That is
an arbitrarily large source
of or it's not an arbitrarily large
source of free energy, but it's a large
source of free energy. And it's a large
sink for entropy, a kind of arbitrarily
large sink for entropy. So the second
law of thermodynamics says the entropy
of this entire system counting
the whole surrounding environment
doesn't decrease, so it
can increase and still satisfy the
second law. So this gives you the
classical 19th century heat
death of the Universe idea.
And so your proposed machine
is sitting somewhere embedded in
this gigantic environment that
can provide some finite amount of free
energy but can exhaust effectively an
arbitrary amount of entropy.
So any machine has to dissipate
entropy as it runs to fill up this
kind of arbitrary sink
of entropy that's the classical rest of
the Universe. Now, compare that to the
picture in Quantum theory. The picture
in Quantum theory is the Universe, by
definition, is an isolated system.
So its total information content
doesn't change, right?
It's evolving. unitarily unitary
operations preserve information, so
they're just moving information around.
So from
the point of view of any local system,
the local system is getting information
from its environment, so it sees its
environment losing information, so
gaining entropy.
What this tells us is that entropy is,
in fact, not a
globally definable quantity.
Entropy is always defined relative to
some observer, some division, some
boundary. And this
is another kind of big change in
the last few decades and has led to,
for example, entropic definitions of
time. My local external
time arrow is whatever
direction I see entropy increasing the
most.
So, again, I would refer to people like
Rovelli and Max Taymar,
who developed many of these ideas.
Awesome. All right,
thank you, Chris, and Aguirre looking
forward to seeing everyone's questions
submitted and their preparation and
participation and measurement in the
discussion section. So thank you. Till
next time. All right. Thanks again,
Daniel. Thank you. Aguirre we'll see you
later.